what is
love what do you think this thing is
uh like uh our attachment to other human
beings
and is it something that we should give
to just a few people yes
that's for sure when i was working with
dl hughley in his book
he didn't use the term but he was
describing like
low-key depression and he talked about
how he was in the airport
and he noticed a girl had a red dress
and he went up and thanked her and she
was like waiting for
and he had realized he hadn't registered
color in like weeks
and i think love is like that when you
see
someone and you just like oh like
like your eyes are open like this is
something i've never seen before or
i want more of this that kind of thing
it's really
uh it really disorients
and reorients your thinking don't you
find that like
the world is full of that like non-stop
it's not just like a person
either it's like but it yes but when
it's in a person it's a whole other
level because it's like
i could have this is gonna be great for
years it's like
you know every day it's something new i
mean that that is and that is rare
do you think it's rare i mean find
someone who you could talk to them for
years and not run out of things to talk
about that's true for years yes
that's rare and know that they really
if you leave the room they will do right
by you
that's really rare well
from a russian perspective you just
don't give them another choice
you